[MUSIC]
We have just about 45 minutes.
Maybe, 44 minutes because you may have to
leave punctually at 1.
Am I correct about that?
So, I wanna, I wanna save most of the time
for
your comments and questions to which I
will do my best to, to respond.
[COUGH]
I wanna talk about three things briefly.
I was asked to talk about leadership and I
will do so.
I wanna talk about the climate crisis and
the solutions to the climate crisis.
You'd be surprised if I didn't.
And then, I wanna say a few words on
sustainable capitalism, because as
B-School students you are focused
naturally on the future of business.
And, I have strong views about the state
of business,
the state of markets and the future of
business.
First of all on leadership.
I, thank you for inviting me to speak on
the topic.
I don't hold myself out as a, an expert on
leadership,
I think that a based on my experience and
what I have tried to learn
about leadership, I would start with the
saying by Loutse.
Who wrote of truly great leaders, that
people will say we did this ourselves.
Worth reflection.
I have studied leadership,
I've had the privilege of being in a
number of positions where I
was called upon to provide leadership to
organizations and groups of men and women.
And, there are obviously many different
styles of leadership,
and all I can do is speak to you about the
style and
approach that I think makes the most
sense.
We as human beings are each equipped with
our own
independent ability to collect
information, process it
process the feelings and intuitions that
we have and
to make decisions e, individually and as a
part of groups.
Businesses are groups of people, and
success is,
at the risk of a cliche, a team sport.
And the leader of a team has to motivate
individuals,
but has to be conscious of the reality of
the team.
How do you do that?
Let me give you a very arcane analogy
that's based on information technology.
Here we are in Silicon Valley, so maybe
that'll be okay.
In the history of computing, the first
computers were based
on central processing units surrounded by
fields of memory.
And, as the memory fields grew, and the
processing power grew,
limitations to that model soon appeared.
In structural terms,
the central processing unit would send out
to the field of memory, collect data,
bring it back to the center, process it,
and then store the answer.
As the speed requirements advanced,
it became clear that this was a limitation
both in time and
in the generation of energy, which had
implications for
the size and materials, necessary and
design of computers.
IBM's first breakthrough was called vector
processing.
It's initial success was really based on
that advance,
which simply meant that the central
processing unit, when sending out to
retrieve process and then distribute the
results of information processing.
One of these trips could begin while
others were in progress.
And so, that saved time, speed it up, the
computer, but
all of the processing still had to take
place in the central processing unit.
So, in the early in the 19 80s an
architectural design breakthrough
took place empowered by the relentless
advance of Morris Law,
as processors became smaller and more
powerful.
The central processing unit was broken up,
and smaller microprocessors were placed
throughout the field of memory.
And, with advances in software design, it
became possible to issue the machine
a start order at which moment, all of the
information that needed
to be processed to produce the desired
result could be processed simultaneously
throughout the memory field, where it was
stored adjacent to microprocessors.
And then, the various fractions of the
answer could be
brought to the center and assembled.
So, instead of three trips, there was one
trip.
Faster, less heat energy generated,
smaller machines, faster still, a virtuous
cycle.
So, what does that analogy have to say
about leadership in organizations?
If the leader of an organization insists
on being
provided all of the information necessary
to make every single decision,
it is like the central processing unit
architecture.
And it is a cumbersome process generating
energy taking time.
And, it does not maximize the assets of
the organization in the minds and
hears of the men and women who make up the
organization.
So, how do you make it possible for
a human organization to process all of
the parts of information, of the
information available to the organization.
Simultaneously, in real time, and then
assemble the answers, so
that the team as a whole can move swiftly
and effectively.
Well, to return to the analogy, in the
analogy of,
of the transition and computing design
from CPU base to
massively parallel processing
architectures, the key is the software.
I skipped right through that step very
quickly.
But obviously, in order for the start
order to trigger simultaneous
processing by multiple processors
throughout the memory field.
And then,
direct the parts of the answer towards the
center, then assemble the answer.
That requires very complex software.
So, a leader in a human organization has
to do something analogues
to that software, and all simplifications
can conceal as much as they reveal.
So, with that in mind, I'll just offer
this simplification,
which is hardly original with me, but,
and, you may recognize it.
But, vision, values, and goals.
The vision of the organization is central.
And the leader of any human organization
has to take primary responsiblity
for communicating that vision clearly.
I say communicating, it has to be shared,
not only in words,
not only in data, but emotionally,
spiritually.
It has to be embodied in the way the
leader interacts with every
part of the organization.
Secondly, values are central.
There has to be an agreement as broadly
and as tightly as possible among
all the individuals in the organization on
values and what I mean by values,
it is not just what the, the word
instantly conveys, but, but
but also I mean it in this sense, what
ethical and business criteria
are suppose to be used in making a
decision?
If there is widespread agreement among all
of the individuals in
the organization about those criteria,
about those values,
if you will, then it is more likely than
not
that any individual in the organization
confronted with the same information,
empowered by a commitment to pursue the
same vision, will make a decision
that is quite similar to what anyone else
in the organization would make.
So there is a congruency of vision, a
congruency of values, then goals.
There has to be a time ordered sequence
that reflects
a sensible priority listing of what goals
are most important at any given time.
And then of course, you know the old
cliche, you have to avoid at all cost,
letting the urgent displace the important
because a sense of
urgency is simply not the same as a sense
of priority.
So the role of a leader then begins to be
clarified, at least in my mind.
The leader of an organization has to take
responsibility for
constantly elevating the vision.
A rekindling, a commitment to the vision.
Reiterating constantly, exactly what the
vision is.
What is the purpose of the organization?
What are we trying to accomplish together?
Secondly, the leader has to be responsible
for
constantly reenforcing the values of the
organization.
Not brooking compromise on core values.
And also translating those values into the
practical
criteria upon which decisions are supposed
to be based.
And the leader third has to be responsible
for keeping track of the ever-changing
list of priority goals and the sequence in
which they are supposed to be pursued.
That to me is a formula that works,
there're other models, there're other ways
to go about it, but
for my part that's what I would like to
share with you about leadership.
Now secondly.
The climate crisis.
Perhaps you know everything you wanna know
about it.
But if you are not personally thinking
about and engaged in the development of
solutions for the climate crisis, then you
haven't thought clearly enough about it.
Because by the time you are my age, it
will be crystal clear
that the failures in the early part of the
21st Century to address climate
change effectively were catastrophically
tragic.
We still have time to avoid the,
the worst unacceptable consequences of the
climate crisis.
But, we have to get busy right away.
and, and there is a a massive amount of
denial.
You know the old cliche, denial ain't just
a river in Egypt.
Along side that you could say disparaging
just a tyre in the trunk.
There are people that move directly from
denial right through the oh my god moment
to despair.
Without pausing to actually solve the
problem that needs to be addressed.
And it seems a forbidding task because the
scale of the challenge is so vast.
In essence we are facing a completely new
reality on this planet.
And it is so new and so unfamiliar that
the temptation is to label it implausible.
Or at least, to search out for
any acceptable excuse for doubting whether
it is real.
And, and holding on to those doubts in
order to justify
waiting before the, the time when it's
necessary to really focus on it.
We don't have the luxury of time anymore.
Here, here are the basic facts.
Global warming is simply the largest and
by far the most significant manifestation
of a deeper underlying
collision between human civilization as it
is presently organized.
And the ecological system of the planet
which has empowered human beings and
nourished the flourishing of human
civilization.
There have been three changes that have
coincided to create a radical
discontinuity in the historical
relationship between the human species.
And Planet Earth.
Number one is population.
I won't belabor this, but when the
scientists tell us that we first,
emerged in, roughly, our modern form
approximately 200,000 years ago,
midway between the second-to-last and
third-to-last Ice Age.
We are a creature for all seasons.
I'm going to resist the temptation to go
too deeply into any of these points.
But, be that as it may, it has taken
200,000
years before we reached the population of
one billion people.
Sometime around the beginning on the 19th
century.
We added that many people in the first 13
years of this century.
We will add another billion in the next 14
years.
And yet another billion 15 to 16 years
after that.
We, we may stabilize global population at
nine or ten billion.
There is a good deal of uncertainty about
the projections simply because the base
is now so large that fractions of a child,
an odd phrase, I know.
But fractions of a child.
In the projections make the difference
between nine billion and
14 billion or 18 billion we do know well,
let me pause and say that this enormous
population explosion,
they used to call it can be looked at in
retrospect.
By noting that we have quadrupled human
population in less than 100 years.
And that has contributed to this radical
change in
the relationship between our species and
the planet.
We could have many more people with a
completely different lifestyle,
different technologies and a different
civilization, but
given the stickiness of legacy
technologies and lifestyles.
it, it is fair to assume that we really do
need to stabilize population.
In that regard, we are witnessing a
success story unfolding in slow motion.
Actually, we have seen the development in
the last quarter century.
Of a very powerful and
durable consensus worldwide on exactly how
to stabilize population.
This is a success.
I doesn't look like it but, but,
sometimes, but it is.
It's a systems problem.
Population dynamics is not a single cause,
single effect.
Issue there are multiple factors involved,
but here is the distillation of
what social scientists have, have, have
learned and proven in the field.
There are four factors, all of which have
to be present, but
when these four factors are present in any
society.
Population changes from one equilibrium
state to another equilibrium state,
it's an S curve.
The first equilibrium state is high birth
rates,
high death rates, and large families.
Down the S-curve at the end of the
transition, the demographic transition,
as they call it.
There is a second equilibrium state.
Small low birth rates, low death rates,
and small families.
Small families are actually preferred by
people.
During the agricultural revolution there
was a premium on having larger families.
There are many other factors involved.
But basically, the challenge has been how
to move
societies around the world from one
equilibrium state to the other.
That's where these four factors come in.
Number one.
The education of girls.
Number two, the empowerment of women.
Number three, the ubiquitous or nearly
ubiquitous availability
of fertility management techniques and
technologies and knowledge.
Number four, perhaps most significantly,
low child death rates.
How does that last one fit in?
If parents have confidence that their
children will survive into adulthood.
And they have the ability to manage
fertility.
They're going to want smaller families.
If on the other hand, there is a high
child mortality rate,
then mothers and fathers will want to
have large families in order to ensure
that some of their children survive.
Into adulthood, particularly in, in
societies where there are not,
Social Security, type programs, and
family, support is essential, in, in old
age.
Now the good news is we made a lot of
progress in educating girls and
empowering women.
Not nearly enough.
But we are on the right track all over the
world.
We have also made a lot of progress in
reducing child death rates,
really quite dramatic progress.
Where we have lagged behind is making
fertility management available,
particularly in places like Sub-Saharan
Africa,
where the replacement rate is still much
higher than, than the global average.
Africa, as a consequence midway through
this century, not long from now,
will have more people than either China or
India.
And at the end of this century, will have
more people than China and India combined.
But in much of the world, this transition,
the demographic transition has taken place
in all the developed countries, North
America, Europe, Japan, et cetera.
Even in in, in China.
Brazil, the BRICs, the emerging economies.
They're, they're all.
Mexico.
They, they, they are all coming down this
S curve.
So this is a good news, it's a, a positive
development.
But those that have, that, that are not
getting fertility management, have a right
to expect that wealthy developed
countries, principally the United States.
Will actually follow through on the
pledges made to help them
get access to fertility management, this
is the, the one problem there.
Anyway, that's the first factor, even
though it's a success story, the large
increase in population has changed the
relationship we have to the planet.
Second, and far more significant, is the
technology revolution
that took a turn 150 years ago, after the
first Industrial Revolution.
Powered by coal, the first oil well was
drilled a century and half ago.
And in the 20th century, the combination
of oil and
coal became the basis of energy in the
world.
And today, 85% of the energy used by Earth
Inc,
the global economy, comes from fossil
fuels.
And as a result, we now put 90 million
tons everyday of heat trapping,
global warming pollution that's dumped in
to the atmosphere every 24 hours.
As if the atmosphere is an open sewer.
You know, in the 19th century a, a great
doctor in England
was dealing with a cholera epidemic, which
used to be one of the biggest killers.
And he innovated a location based data
system and
mapped all of the cases of cholera in
London.
And overlaid it on the sewer system and
found that a single malfunctioning pump on
Broad Street was the proximate cause of
the cholera epidemic.
Not long after that Louis Pasteur
discovered the bacteria that was
responsible for cholera, and
the, it is no longer the, the major cause
of death in the world that it used to be.
He connected the dots, an, and it traced
to the sewer system.
We have to connect the dots between the 90
million tons of global warming pollution
spewed into the atmosphere every day, the
decision to use the atmosphere as a sewer,
and the, and the resulting consequences of
all that extra trapped heat.
We're raising the temperature of the
planet.
In fact, the accumulated man-made global
warming pollution now traps as much
extra energy in, in the, in the atmosphere
every day as would be released
by 400,000 Hiroshima-style atomic bombs
every single day.
It's a big planet, but that's a lot of
energy, and
that's what evaporating much more water
vapor from the oceans into the warmer air
of the atmosphere, which has an increased
holding power.
Holding capacity for water vapor.
So when storm conditions release a
downpour,
the storms reach out 2,000 kilometers off
and
then funnel these rivers of water vapor in
the sky into these massive downpours
that are breaking records all over the
world, creating these floods.
The same extra heat is pulling the
moisture out of
the soil making massive droughts much more
widespread and much more frequent.
The extra heat in the oceans is powering
much stronger wind speeds,
which makes the storms more destructive,
melting the ice,
50% of the Arctic ice cap is now gone, as
of last September.
All of it will be gone in the next 10, 20
years.
And that's changing the pattern of the jet
stream, and the storm tracks.
It is disrupting the age, the timing of
precipitation events and
the clockwork of rainy season, dry season
alternation in,
in developing countries disrupting
sustainable agriculture.
Not sustainable.
Subsistence agriculture in countries where
that is the principal occupation.
The melting ice raises sea level.
You know the rest.
Moves disease vectors from the tropics and
sub-tropics into the temperate zones.
And the list of horribles is actually much
longer than that.
The tendency in the face of such evidence
is to turn away from it.
And that is, that leads to the third cause
after, population and
technology, and that is our way of
thinking.
We are empowered with thought patterns and
habits that we have inherited from our
ancient ancestors.
And as has often been the case in the
history of civilization,
our real challenge is to accelerate the
emergence.
Of wisdom that can be used to deal with
new circumstances.
We're built for that, we are creatures of
habit we, we do
manifest the legacies of our evolutionary
paths but, we also have the capacity
to rise above our limitations and to see
clearly the changes that need to be made.
One of the things that needs to change is
our vulnerability to short term thinking.
Now our present culture in business, in
media, in politics, in almost every
realm of life has now magnified this
tendency to focus on the short term.
And made it a very serious problem.
So let me use that as a segue to the third
topic that I'll cover very briefly, and
then open it up to your questions and
comments.
Sustainable capitalism.
Short-termism, you, you no doubt have
already identified that as a buzzword,.
It is an extremely serious problem.
One of our leading business research
institutions BNA, conducted a famous study
a few years ago in which they asked CEOs
and CFOs a whole series of questions.
One of them was a hypothetical.
Here's a, an investment you can make in
your business, the question began.
If you make this investment,
you're business will become more
profitable, stronger, more sustainable,
more resilient, it meets your internal
investment targets.
But there's one, issue.
If you make this investment,
you will slightly miss your next quarter's
earnings projection.
Given those facts, will you make the
investment?
Eighty percent said no.
That is functionally insane.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It truly is.
Because it hurts the shareholders.
It hurts the employees.
it, it hurts the communities where the
business is operating.
But it, it is now a routine decision.
Because, of course missing a quarterly
earnings projection
leads to a reduction in market
capitalization, and
whatever benefits come from focusing on
the long term build up of sustainable
value, could, can be wiped out given the
way financing markets now operate.
so, what do we need to do to reform
capitalism?
Let me first say, it,
it hardly needs to be said particularly in
this group, but capitalism's,
capitalism is the best way of organizing
economic activity ever created.
It allocates resources efficiently,
balances supply and
demand is more congruent with higher
levels of freedom in human societies.
And perhaps, most significantly,
capitalism unlocks a higher fraction of
the human potential.
With a ubiquitous set of organic
incentives that routinely
reward hard work, initiative, creativity
and, and innovation.
>> But in spite of those well documented
strengths,
which had made capitalism the base of
every successful economy in the world and
there are different varieties of
capitalism.
But in essence, it, it, it is ubiquitous
now.
But in spite of those strengths,
capitalism is increasingly being
associated with a series of problems.
Growing inequality.
Almost everywhere in the world, the U.S.,
Europe, Japan, China, India Brazil.
Almost everywhere in the world, inequality
is growing beyond the normal levels.
Inequality is endemic to capitalism.
It's good, we should have inequality.
That's part of the des, that's part of why
this system of incentives works.
But, as with inflation, if you go from a
normal level to a hyper level.
Hyper inflation soaks up so much energy
and
so many resources that the, the normal
functioning comes almost to a halt.
Hyper inequality is threatening to both
ca, both to capitalism and democracy.
Since the, recovery, such as it is, began
after the recent great recession, 93%
of the additional, income in the United
States has indeed gone to the top 1%.
That's not an Occupy Wall Street slogan.
That's a fact.
And while these flows of income have been
channelled to the top, middle
income families have been struggling and
are increasingly struggling.
Okay.
This is not a political polemic,
it is an observation, and the consequences
of this,
again, are threatening to democratic
capitalism.
What else?
A series of disruptions in the global
economy,
occurring with greater frequency and at
higher magnitudes.
Missile-lined incentives, where not, not
just principal agent problems.
But misaligned incentives that lead to, to
allocation, al, decisions and
investment decisions that again don't make
good rational sense.
These problems need to be addressed on
increasing focus on the short term,
as I said earlier.
So what should we do?
I think that there need to be some
significant reforms in the design of
markets and in the design of capitalism.
Since this ubiquitous set of organic
incentives is the key to
unlocking the energy in markets.
We need to pay careful attention to what
the incentives are.
People will often do what you pay them to
do.
And if you pay them to focus on the short
term, they will do that.
Even if you also signal to them that you
want them to tell you that
they're focused on the long term, if you
reward them and
pay them al, to focus on the short term,
they will do that.
30 years ago in the U.S.
the average holding period for public
equities was roughly seven years.
Which is congruent with the buildup of
real value in firms.
Now it's less than six months.
And on both of the New York and London
exchange is more than half of the trades
are now made in, by algorithmic computer
trading in, in milliseconds.
So, we need to get rid of this idea that
more liquidity is always better.
We do not have perfect information.
Markets do not tend toward equilibrium.
and, and we need to understand that the
standard model is now obsolete.
What will the new model be, I don't know.
A lot of people think behavioral economics
and
behavioral investing is the leading
candidate.
I kinda think that, but it's above my pay
grade.
So I will let you all figure that out.
Let me conclude, and then open it up to
you.
By telling you, just, just one brief
story.
Because the climate crisis can seem
daunting.
The challenge of fixing capitalism can
seem daunting.
But look, look, things can change very
quickly.
I remember as a, a child, as a young guy,
and growing up in Tennessee.
When the civil rights revolution swept the
country.
I remember when the conversation changed.
Somebody made some racist comment in my
circle, and
somebody else said, nah, we don't go for
that.
And it, in, in millions of conversations
it changed.
Two months ago, saw an article about two
gay men waiting in a long line for pizza.
Holding hands and some homophobe walked
by, made a nasty comment.
Literally every other person in that line
turned on the homophobe and
said hey, shut up.
We don't go for that anymore.
We're winning that conversation.
When the culture shifts, when
conscientiousness changes,
then everything else can change rapidly.
You may have noticed, countries all around
the world are approving gay marriage,
getting rid of the discrimination against
gays and lesbians.
If somebody had asked in your age group,
you wouldn't have been surprised at all,
but in my age group, if somebody had said
five years ago we would see
this revolutionary change, most people
would have said, nah, can't do it.
We're doing it, because consciousness
changed.
That's what has to happen with the
conversation about global warming and
sustainable capitalism.
Now finally.
I remember as a boy of 13 when President
Kennedy issued the challenge to put
a person on the moon and bring him back
safely in 10 years.
And I remember hearing so many say that's
a mistake, we can't do that.
But eight years and two months later, Neil
Armstrong set foot on the moon.
And the moment he did,
so there was a great cheer that went up in
NASA's mission control in Houston.
The average age of those systems engineers
was 26.
Which meant when they heard that
challenge, they were 18.
I know that some of you have come here to
this great institution.
To be of, a part of something larger than
yourself.
I would end by challenging all of you to
aim in that direction.
These are times when it is a privilege to
have the opportunity to do good
things that what will be looked back upon
as a turning point for human civilization.
And business is at the center of the
change that has to take place.
So, we need the will to act, but
always remember that the will to act is
itself a renewable resource.
Thank you very much.
I will open it up to your questions now.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Okay.
We don't have much time.
Don't s, don't waste it on simply
applauding.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Where am I going.
Okay, yes.
>> Mister Vice President, thank you so
much.
>> Tell me who you are when you're asking
questions.
>> Oh sorry.
Name's Alex [UNKNOWN] MBA 1 here.
I wanted to ask you more specifically
about the inequality thing that you
were mentioning.
.
>> Yeah.
>> I've heard a lot, or
you hear often people mention that maybe
that's just the way the economy is moving.
That, you know, the way as it goes to a
more advanced information economy that is
the nature of where the jobs are.
That inequality is a natural progression.
A, do you agree or disagree with that?
Assuming you disagree with that,
how do you get it to the point where you
close that inequality gap?
>> Well I, I, I do disagree with it I, I
think that there are obviously some very
broad structural factors involved, since
it's nearly a global phenomenon.
There are a few countries in South America
that don't manifest it,
in the words of the song, they have been
down so long it looks up to them.
But, in the rest of the word it's, it's
pretty ubiquitous.
I think there a lot of factors involved.
I think the emergence of Earth Inc, with a
combination of outsourcing and
robosourcing advanced automation is a big
part of it.
So that businesses operating with global
supply chains and the ability
to outsource with the transportation
revolution and the internet.
Now a routinely look at labor as the first
place to to cut and and
in contrast to the industrial revolution
when people standing on assembly
lines were making good money and buying
the products coming out of the factories.
Now the increasing levels of automation
that now extend not just to our physical
capacities but, also our cognitive
functions, are really creating a,
a, a very big systemic change.
The so called Luddite fallacy that's been
accepted for,
since Ned Lud lead his revolt, may no
longer be a fallacy.
That's controversial to say, but an
increasing number
of really good economists are, are coming
to that conclusion.
And I think that has an impact.
Here in the United States I think the tax
policy has had
a major impact on inequality.
I think that our democracy is in, in
trouble.
That's another topic and not the one that
I'm talking to you about here, but
I think that elites now have outsized
power.
I, I think there's been a big structural
change in the way we communicate.
the, the, the revolution of the printing
press really lead to the enlightenment and
the emergence of representative democracy.
The shift in the last third of the 20th
century to a television based
ecosystem really changed that.
There's a, a bottleneck through which you
can gain access to
the public's mind only if you have huge
amounts of money.
So corporate special interests now
dominate the messaging that
comes into everybody's living room and on
their screens.
And the average American in spite of the
internets rise still
watches television five hours per day.
Now as the internet gains momentum and
scale.
Television will sink into the digital
universe,
you're seeing it begin to happen now.
And the architecture of the internet based
eco, information ecosystem is similar to
the print ecosystem, in this sense,
individuals have very low entry barriers
and once again reason can be lifted up as
a substitute for wealth and power.
And then changes in labor markets and tax
laws and
political systems can, once again, begin
to reflect the public interest.
But, one way or another, this these levels
of hyper-inequality are unsustainable,
and they're very dangerous as I said, both
to democracy and capitalism.
>> Hi my name is Bronca MBA2 I'm from
Brazil.
I'm curious about your point about
increasing focus in the short term.
And I hear a call to action to future
business leaders, and I
just wanted to understand what do you, how
do you think about the public sector and
the private sector, at least here in the
U.S., and how these two should like,
coordinate to make sure that like, we can
change that mentality?
>> Yeah, well, [UNKNOWN] I,
I think that the, the the dividing line
between private goods and public good,
goods, is in need of clearer focus and a,
and, and attention now.
Democratic capitalism has ideological
hegemony in the world and
has at least since the Berlin wall fell in
1989.
but, that engendered a kind of
triumphalism among market fundamentalists
and the, the internal dividing line
between, in democratic capitalism,
between those who are primarily rooted in
the democracy sphere and
those who are primary, or half sphere.
And those who are primarily rooted in the
market hemisphere.
That line began to shift and
power is now being pulled from political
systems into markets.
a, a, and both capitalism and democracy,
by the way, are manifestations of this
massively parallel
processing of information that I began by
describing in the context of leadership.
Think about it.
And, and both were invented same year,
1776.
That's when Thomas Jefferson wrote the
Declaration of Independence,
that's when Adam Smith published the
Wealth of Nations.
and, and in both systems you see the, the,
the independent decisions
of multitudes of people collected to to
harvest the wisdom of crowds and democracy
and the invisible hand in markets.
Both systems have been hacked.
And I, I don't know if you've seen the,
the work of a, he, he's long since dead,
but Mancur Olson is one of several
theorists who has
described how elites over time during long
periods of stability,
tend naturally to accumulate more power
and influence.
That's happened in the political system,
it's happened in, in the market system.
I do think that one of the solutions to
inequality and
growing structural joblessness is going to
be to put new emphasis on
the generation of public goods.
Now let, let, let, let me say one other
thing briefly.
The dashboard, the compass, the, the, the,
the,
the metric system that we're using to
guide economies, it is completely whacked.
GDP, and the national accounts that are
derived from GDP, and business accounting.
In 1937, the creator of gross domestic
product,
Simon Kuznets, was honored for it, and he
said, thank you very much.
It, I know it's in advance, really, you
know, it was it really was.
But he said, please do not use this as a
guide for national economic policy.
Why?
Because, it's a heuristic.
You know a $10 work that means shortcut.
But a little more than that.
A shortcut that, that becomes embedded in
our thinking and
we think it's the whole thing.
But it's a shortcut.
GDP leaves out a lot.
What does it leave out?
Does not take into account pollution
flows, environmental externalities.
Does not mether, measure the distribution
of income, so
inequality doesn't show up on the
dashboard.
If we get an increase in national income,
and 93% of it go,
does go to the top 1%, that's a big win
for all of us, right?
Well, no.
But on the dashboard it looks like it's,
it's, it's a big win.
What else is left out?
Well, depletion of natural resources.
But, here's the one that I'm getting to.
In addition to negative externalities like
pollution, positive externalities are,
are, are left out.
So that if a community or a nation,
invests in education, mental health care,
community building etc.
That shows up as an expense.
But the positive benefits that come
flowing back into
society are not measured.
They're not put on the balance sheet.
And so when we face a fiscal challenge to,
to you know,
rebalance the books, you wanna cut that
spending without, but if you have no
knowledge that you're also eliminating all
of those benefits, you know.
I mean, infrastructure people understand
that that's a public good, because it,
it's measured derivatively from the stuff
that is on the the balance sheet
that depends on the infrastructure, but
education, mental health care,
these other things, they're not measured.
So we really do have to take a close look
at this.
Now let me say we're gonna run out of
time, but I wanna challenge all of you
to use the skills and talents that you're
acquiring here.
And congratulations on being accepted
here, on being able to stay here,
on doing what you're doing.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But to whom much is given, much is
required.
That's another cliche, but, but I wanna
leave you today.
I know that they're gonna, I don't know if
you ring a bell or blow a whistle or, or
what, but I don't wanna be caught standing
while everybody gets up and leaves.
So, so let, let me just conclude by
thanking you for
the opportunity to spend this time with
you.
I'm very, very grateful.
But I want to conclude by challenging you.
We need your help.
This is really and
truly a moment not only unlike any other,
it's, it's different in kind.
This is a, a moment when all of us really
have to rise to an unprecedented
challenge, and years from now when you're
my age, your kids, you know, will look
around them at the world that they live in
and they'll ask one of two questions.
You know if there are hundreds of millions
of climate refugees and
failures of governance in countries around
the world at rising seas, and
stronger storms, and deeper droughts, and
bigger floods and
a collapse of of, of, of, of civilized
norms in different places.
Challenges to the food supply and the
water supply.
They'll look, they,
they would be justified in asking you why
didn't you do anything about this?
But if they look around them and see a
world in renewal,
with a massive shift to renewable energy
and efficiency and
a whole systems thinking and a sense of
hope in people's hearts and
a regeneration of the life and vitality of
the earth and of human populations.
They will ask you, how did you rise to
this challenge.
And you have to decide which of those
questions you want to
answer while you're here.
And equip yourselves to be apart of given,
and part of the answer will
be that you went to Stanford Business
School, you got the skills and
knowledge and then you decided to use them
in an effective and appropriate way.
Thank you very much for having me here
today.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Thank you, thank you.
[MUSIC]